i am having the best conversation with
emmy and golden globe winning valerie
bertinelli
um
another thing that really moved me about
you is how much i relate to the hustle
you know
i do i have lived a life where i kind of
never know where the next job is coming
from
uh yes it's a very glamorous uh
privileged incredible business that we
are in
but it's filled with uncertainty
and
you are a amazing chef you've got emmy
awards you know for your shows the food
network discovery plus the books are
flying out this is all the hustle and i
just don't appreciate it because these
are not the things that fall in our lap
these are the things that we have to go
out there and create for ourselves and i
had mass admiration and respect
for you and all that you're
accomplishing right now
you know drew i think you may feel the
same way too i don't feel like i'm
hustling i'm just like what's next what
can i learn what's interesting to me
what can i do now and to be given the
opportunity to be able to do it like
food network was so wonderful to me was
it six seven years ago that i started
working with them and they've given me
the opportunity to do these things and i
never feel like i'm i mean hustle such a
great word because i i know that i'm in
it but i never feel like it's
drudgery it's it's exciting i'm learning
so many new things and i think that is
our main purpose here we need to learn
to get better to do better to be kinder
to learn more to use our every single
person in this world is artistic i
guarantee it there is something in you
that can can let your emotion out and
when you find it it just feels so
freeing you're absolutely right in fact
i'm taking out the word hustle and
everything about it because it's i'm a
word obsessed person and i do like it
it's got like a moxie there are certain
words it's a great word a little like
tail feather like
a hustle
i
do i do feel like it's almost like
bustle it's prolificness it's like a
life lived where i recognize in you that
you take from your surroundings pull
from it and turn it into something
and that is an incredible skill set that
you have
and i admire about you and i welcome it
to us all because i've lived a life
where i'm very clear that things do not
fall on your lap i always say that phone
doesn't magically ring i'll build that
phone and call people with it instead
yes and that yes and everybody can do
that yeah everybody can do it and that
is what i recognize and admire about you
and relate to
i i relate to it and girl you have the
exact right job right now you are doing
so so much for so many people you are
connecting so many people together
making us all feel so good about
ourselves you are in the right place
right now and you are doing
the best work thank you for that if you
think i'm doing an okay job i'm
i'm so happy because i so much respect
for you
i i really do all right so may i ask
about your new show that you are doing
uh with demi lovato uh your character as
written sounds like something you can
totally chew on and dive into pun
intended i'm excited for this is it
happening uh like yes
well we're shooting the pilot in about a
month um
uh and it's by one of my favorite the
same woman suzanne martin who wrote hot
in cleveland wrote a show called hungry
for demi lovato and luckily
suzanne was thinking about me for her
mother so uh and i say her because
that's her characters or her yeah when i
talk about demi i say they yes um and
they are
so amazing in this we we shot a pilot
and i'm telling you nothing has been
more perfect for demi
either they are in the right place at
the right time
and
they're doing amazing work in this show
and i am so grateful that suzanne wanted
me for it i'm so grateful that nbc said
yes you can cast her because i think
this is a show that everybody is going
to want we're all talking about the the
the diet craziness and and our bodies
and do they define us and um do you
are you defined by your body no you're
not and just making that funny and smart
and i i hope it gets picked up by nbc
i'm very excited about it
and i'm excited for all of your next
chapters and you need to give ross a hug
for me i will i will and by the way i
have four cats
so there's one of mine right now here's
tigger
i have four cats and i want a cat lady
out with you
and
so again next time you come to los
angeles you're gonna come over and hang
out with me and my cats and my dog okay
good thank you i got the invitation i'm
in it's happening thank you valerie
nelly pick up your own copy of enough
already out everywhere now and you can
catch all of the new episodes of kids
baking championship on mondays at 8 pm
on food network
[Music]